Well, the time has come.
Pauley Perrette's Abby Sciuto has now left
the NCIS team.
On May 8th's episode, Abby finally decided
to pack her bags and head off to start a new
life in London after enduring a gunshot wound
and facing down the person responsible for
her attack all alone.
Fans have been bracing for the character's
exit for months, and yet, it's still a little
hard to accept that her time on the show is
through.
There've been a lot of rumors surrounding
Pauley Perrette's decision to leave NCIS after
15 seasons, but the actor is doing her best
to dispel all of them.
When Perette first announced in October of
2017 that she'd be giving up her long-lived
role as Abby, the team's intelligent and eccentric
forensic specialist, fans wondered why she
might step away from the career-making role
after spending so many years in those Doc
Martens.
False rumors swirled that she was going to
become a spokeswoman for a skincare line,
but Perrette shot that story down right away.
"And I'm like 'What is going on?'"
In a note to fans, the actress confirmed her
exit but denied the cosmetic connection, by
writing:
"So, it is true that I am leaving NCIS after
this season.
There have been all kinds of false stories
as to why (NO I DON'T HAVE A SKIN CARE LINE
AND NO MY NETWORK AND SHOW ARE NOT MAD AT
ME!)."
That might've cleared some of the bizarre
rumors about her decision to leave -- after
all, she's certainly not the first actor to
leave a hit series to pursue other projects
-- but the speculation still continued.
This time, buzz suggested that trouble had
been brewing behind the scenes and that the
actress could no longer tolerate it.
However, it's since become clear that Perrette
departed on good terms.
NCIS executive producers George Schenck and
Frank Cardea told Variety that they had "known
for some time" that season 15 of the series
would be Perrette's last, and that everyone
involved on the show wanted to give her a
memorable send-off.
The pair said in a joint statement:
"From day one, she has brought incredible
passion and specificity to the role.
Abby is a character that inspires millions
of fans around the world, and all of us at
NCIS are appreciative of Pauley for portraying
her."
Perrette herself later spoke up to assure
fans that there wasn't any drama behind her
departure, as she told TV Insider:
"I believe in God and the universe so firmly,
and it just suddenly became blindingly apparent
that now was the time.
After a lot of thought, I decided to announce
it myself on Twitter because I didn't want
it to be turned into anything 'shocking.'
Abby leaving is more than a cheap TV ploy."
Perrette may be missing from NCIS in the future,
leaving Ducky and Mark Harmon's Leroy Gibbs
as the only remaining original cast members,
but the mark she left on the series and the
impact she had on its fans won't soon be forgotten.
"Abby has been this incredible role model
for young women."
"Thousands and thousands and thousands of
young women that have been inspired by a television
character, and now they're truly out there
changing the world."
So, even though fans have said goodbye to
Abby Sciuto on the show, her cultural impact
will certainly continue.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!